you're beautiful thank you no no no
hearse
looks better you look quite handsome
while she looks very beautiful yeah I
love your dress it's got it's actually
pants with this like it's kind of a mess
Ashley it just looks like bandages no no
you look good well this is there's
openings in the side I didn't see the
side of your yeah it's incredible no
it's true it's it's just I'm just saying
I'm being an honest that would be great
for shoplifting yeah that's why you have
it we look very nice look at that now
you've ruined everything sorry you're
sitting you're sitting with three
perverts on a subway right and you're
just waiting for your stop I just want
to get off I just want to get off you
know I know that you're from UK you're
from just outside London I am get from
how far outside my box it's about 40
minutes outside of London okay and I am
interested because a couple of years ago
you were here working in the States
getting jobs as an actress and you got a
chance to play Kate Middleton I did in a
lifetime series called William and Kate
was in a TV movie TV movie yeah TV movie
called
you're not a series I'm sorry but a
Lifetime movie about William and Kate
yeah you play Kate Middleton and you
people really liked it here but then
they showed it in England and I was
curious life time yeah lifetime movie is
a very specific kind of entertainment
how'd it go over in England we don't
have life time in England so like they
don't understand that like Lifetime
movies are cheesy and guilty pleasure
they're fun they're fun to watch like
you've got a bottle of wine and your
girlfriend's well in England I knew I
was screwed with the reviews before even
came out because they were comparing it
to the next King speech and I was like
oh my god I know they thought it was a
serious like serious drama maybe you
know slightly controversial and then it
came out and they were like what is this
including my family your family what did
you what did your family think they
thought it was interesting I remember I
told my
interesting sever a good word
interesting is the word I can think of
um I told them not to send me reviews
and they took great joy in sending me so
many horrible reviews like I always say
please please please don't send me
anything and they be like what like this
one stop the Daily Mail gave you and
they'd like take a picture of it and
send it to me and it was horrible so
they thought it was like hysterically
funny but it was my mommy when I first
got in television my mom used to say to
me I'm just gonna punch that guy who
write and there was some newspaper that
nobody reads that writer for the Rhode
Island Post Dispatch I'm gonna punch him
in the nose I don't think you're
effeminate
you